- [Instructor] A crate of honey bees
arrived at my house by accident,
so I took them immediately
to animal control.
All right, so what is this pronoun, them,
trying to refer to?
As it might be tempting to say
that it's referring to the honey bees,
but the subject of this first part,
this first clause of the
sentence right over here,
they didn't say honey
bees arrived at my house,
they say a crate of honey bees.
So the subject here is actually singular,
it's a crate, a crate.
This right over here is singular.
So when we use the pronoun,
we also want the singular form.
You could try it out
by replacing it with the
word that it's referring to.
A crate of honey bees arrived
at my house by accident,
so I took the crate
immediately to animal control.
So instead of the crate,
I wouldn't say them, I would say it.
I would replace the plural pronoun
with the singular, with
the singular pronoun.
So I took it immediately
to animal control.
This is a very, this is one
that'll, will trip many
people up many times
because you see a singular thing
that contains many things,
and so you might say,
okay, well there, I'm talking
about a lot of honey bees,
so I wanna use plural.
Well, that would be the case
if we just said, honey bees
arrived at my house my accident,
so I took them immediately
to animal control.
That would actually be okay.
But we're not talking
about honey bees arriving,
we're talking about a crate,
one crate of honey bees arriving.
So the pronoun here is referring
to that one crate,
so it should be it.